*Some funky jams*
*Assumingly from Mario Kart*
*Idk I'm dumb* (Other subber says no you're not but idk either)
Rekt
*ded*
M: Hey guys, welcome to the
Mario Kart racing challenge!
I'm here with my crew of Mario here,
Also known as Team Edge™
My lover Mario Matthias
Aaand Tyler's over there!
Dunno why we invited a damn dirty ape to this race.
Alright, so before this we did a qualifying race
to see what order we were gonna
start out the Go-kart challenges.
So the order is... UH. *Tyler pounds of chest* W-NO.
Here's the results.
*Dafuq Marthias?*
*Tyler laughs*
M: Why would you sniff me?
So the order is...
JFred at 8.14 seconds
Here's a neat diagram over Tyler's face
Mat: That's JFred
Mark: Cause no one needs to see him.
Uh
Then its Bryan at 8.29 seconds
Tyler at 8.44
Matt at 8.78
and me at a glorious 9.67
*Muffled clapping* (Nice job Mark xD)
That was horrible
Shut up
I mean I love yooou
We're not gonna do the Grand Pre-race
it's an onslaught endurance race of 100 laps
we're gonna go as fast as we can, whoever is the winner or at least doesn't die-
*dramatically blows hair out of face*
*and again*
-wins me
I'm the prize
So anyway
Let The Race Begin!
*VERY loud dramatic music!*
okay
alright
Don't touch me!
Don't- No.
*I don't even...*
*Start sound?*
*cart sounds*
o-oh dude that was- ah my ankle!
*A lot of yells*
*Cheering*
Woo *Mark yelling in the background?*
*There is more yelling*
Matt: Ow- Ahaha
*more yelling with Matt in the background 'ow'ing*
*Mark victory yelled*
*Yelling and kart noises*
*Mark's high pitch yell*
*The others yell*
Matt: I got through!
*Box noises muffle audio*
*muffled talking*
*Matt cheers in victory*
JFred: What was hurting-
Tyler: Bryan's first
I'm second, Mark's in third
Mark: Oh-ho
*Matt yelling!*
*Matt still yelling but it's words I can't hear..*
Mark: *laughing* My wig!
*more yelling :)*
*Matt laughs*
*Mark yells*
Bryan: Woo!
*Matt, Mark and Tyler in the background*
Tyler: Noo!
Mark: Try to back up
*laughing* I'm backing up
*Matt laughs?*
Mark: I think you're busted, go back!
*LOUD box crashing sounds!*
Tyler: Bryan's in first
I'm in second... I don't know where Mark is
Mark: I'm somewhere in there
Matt: I passed Mark!
Mark: Well- I passed you before so you jus-
*Matt in the background*
Mark: You gotta pass me one more time!
JFred: Let's do this I'm gonna catch up!
*Yelling*
*Someone wooped*
*Laughing mixed with the yelling*
Matt: What happened?
JFred: I can't up *laughs*
Bryan: This part broke too
JFred: I just ran into it cause, cause it got stuck
Bryan: Welp he's outta the race
Wanna explain the places after the crash reset?
Tyler: I'm winning.
So they all crashed into JFred in the corner
and JFred was like "AHHH!"
and I just passed everyone like a BOSS!
*funny 'ehhh' sound, thanks Mark.*
Mark: Oh-ho!
*Matt screams*
*more screams from Matt*
*Quieter yells from Matt*
Tyler: *Laughing* I was trying ta stop
right before you started screaming
WAIT why where you still going?!
Bryan: I didn't hear 'stop'
Tyler: JFred split our- *Laughs*
Matt: JFred?
Tyler: *Still laughing* Matthias' foot got stuck under my wheel
*Bryan yelling*
*laughing*
*excessive yelling/ laughing*
*Thud*
*Mark screams*
*Matt 'Oh!'s*
Matt: Time!
*A mix of laughing, 'are you okay?' and 'oh's*
K pretty sure you got lapped now Tyler
Tyler: I didn't get lapped!
Yeah you did
Tyler: No! I had a lap on everyone!
Bryan did a good job on closing you off
*Bryan laughs*
Tyler: No, they- they passed me but I already lapped them six times.
*mock agreement (Sure Tyler)*
Bryan: You can only be lapped once
Mark: *mocking the six*
Tyler: I'm coming for you!
*CRASH*
*WOAH*
*Loud noises and yelling*
JFred: Don't hit the boxes
Mark: You guys SUCK
*Matt? Yelling*
Matt: Oh my gosh dude I'm so dizzy!
Matt: Oh I can't- okay, okay I got it
Mark: Woooah!
*Loud thud*
*Laughing* (dude! haha)
Run Mark
Mark: Ahah
Matt: You alright?
Mark: I'm good!
Little wheely
*Mark blowing hair from hair*
Matt: Wow
Tyler: Wah!
Matt: WOAH!
Matt: I'm lapping everyone baby!
Mark: Your competitive nature is working against ya!
*Mark scream*
*Tyler yells*
*Winner sounds and clapping*
Oh that was final lap?
Tyler: Woah!
Tyler: I wheelied across that finish line
*Matt and Mark yell*
*more yelling*
*Laughing and 'ow' sounds at the same time*
Bryan: That woulda hurt
Mark: Jeez
Bryan: You alright?
Tyler: I'm good
Mark: Get him while he's down!
*laughing*
Matt: Get while he's down!
*Mark makes 'Eyyyy' noises*
*Mark starts get get concerned while 'Eyyy-'ing
*Now he's screaming realizing his mistake*
*Mario death music* (RIP)
Mark: Okay so
Tyler: It's so hot *bangs on chest*
Mark: DK was the winner
*laughing*
Mark: If you didn't tell by him shouting it every single time he passed someone
Mark: ''I'm winning, I'm winning! Oh look at me you guys suck, I'm winning!''
Bryan: I lapped you ten times!
Mark: And then like the winners thing was thrown in front of him
so none of us even got a chance to win
anyway so
he wins me, he's gonna take me home
Don't- Oh God no!
so
anyway yeah, screw you Mario!
Fuck all you guys
*Matt is crying lol*
Mark: So I count that a win for my team
Team Edge can suck it!
So thanks everybody for watching
Check out their channel for the 'Super Hot' challenge
You know the 'Super Hot' game, well we're gonna do that in real life
Links in the description and thanks again
See you in the next one
BYE BYE~!
(Lovely dress Mark!)